JEN PERSON: This
week, we're talking
about moving from 2019
to 2020, accessing
VPC resources from
serverless code,
and where to run
your containers.
I'm Jen Person.
And welcome to "This Weekend
Cloud," where we serve you
the lowest-latency news.
We're glad to be back in 2020.
And we've got just the thing
to start this year off.
We've assembled some
New Year's resolutions
to guide you toward
operating a faster, more
efficient cloud infrastructure.
Check out these tips
to improve your skills
and your architecture.
And of course, if you're not
ready to leave 2019 behind,
we've also got a recap of some
of the biggest announcements
and stories from last year.
From hybrid to databases
to machine learning,
a lot happened in cloud in 2019.
So make sure to get
caught up on stories
you may have missed,
and let them inspire you
for the new year.
If you've ever wanted to
access your private resources
from your serverless
app, look no further.
Serverless VPC access
lets you do exactly
that, giving you an access
point that lets your App Engine
and Cloud Functions connect
to VMs and other resources
with just a few lines
of configuration.
Support for Cloud
Run is coming soon.
So don't let your VPC silo
your resources any longer.
Did you know there's
three easy ways
to run your containers
in Google Cloud?
Alexis gives us the details
on how you can run containers
with your Google
Kubernetes Engine,
Cloud Run, and even
Compute Engine.
Watch the video
for more details.
And stay tuned for more episodes
of Google Cloud Essentials.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.